what was that flash mob like when you
when you saw everyone break out i was
not expecting that that doesn't happen
my everyday life when i'm walking into
the street like oh there's like 40 weird
owls like singing i love rocky road uh
that was pretty crazy this is the
perfect audience a midnight madness oh
yeah what can you expect inside do you
think you're gonna break out in song and
sort of just go crazy for this movie i
don't know you know i've never been to
tiff or midnight madness before but from
what i hear it is in fact the perfect
audience for this movie i think they're
going to go absolutely i think their
heads are going to fly off their torsos
i think it's going to get crazy in there
what did you think of daniel's stash was
it was it good was it it was good i mean
you know that that's his real stash you
know he grew that specifically for the
movie and uh you know he he committed to
the role and i i would rate that stash
of 10 out of 10.
what do you think madonna and oprah are
going to think when they see this note
you know oprah apparently is that tip i
don't know where she is but i want to go
oh is she coming to the premiere i
wonder uh hopefully they'll like it i
mean we uh we i have to admit we did not
get their blessings ahead of time uh but
hopefully they have a good sense of
remember about it they understand i'm
sure that it's all in good fun and uh uh
and we'll see
and i know just on a somber note i know
you did god save
uh obviously very sad my wife and i were
talking about that all day today it's uh
uh she's been a part of our entire lives
uh and it is in fact very very sad and
uh we um
you know send along our best wishes for
the royal family thank you so much have
a great night
you